on va accueillir un autre marque il sera
avec nous tous les vendredis c'est un
imitateur qu'on aime beaucoup l'avaient
invité ici il est exceptionnel c'est
marc antoine le break est avec nous
pourquoi est ce qu'on peut vous décalez
est ce que pour décaler les chéris merci
merci merci gilles merguez marc-antoine
le bret qui vient nous donner des
nouvelles des stars du bafin tous les
vendredis il nous donnera des nouvelles
alors on a des nouvelles de bon jour où
on a des nouvelles de philippe bouvard
un bonjour mocean serrer la alors tout
de suite une question de madame françois
hollande a beaucoup d'aix en provence
qui a dit je cite cyril hanouna est un
vendeur d'épinards pouvait répondre à
celle où la s'agit de philippe bogaert
bonne deuxième but tout à fait deuxième
question de madame nafissatou n'avais
pas envie de béziers quoi ai-je dit que
cyril hamelin est un vendeur d'épinards
j'avais une réponse tout simplement vu
l'âge de mes intervenants aux grosses
têtes
je peux vous dire qu'on s'y connaît en
légumes ici on a aussi des nouvelles de
celui qui est très ouvrage qui s'est un
petit peu pris la tête avec gilles
verdez c'est lorànt deutsch
bonsoir franges et raison en est
évidente ou forme on voit star
les succès des invités pour moi c'était
une bonne nouvelle bonne nouvelle les 8
et 9
la station est ouverte au mieux sauter
j'ai fait les fermiers endroit à moi
j'aime beaucoup et j'ai en fait un
problème fut empêchée par une métro tout
le temps c'est comme ça immoraux et peut
pas s'empêcher de faire des vannes
sourire thierry gdba j'ai pas été très
sympa
franchement je me suis un peu moqué ok
niveau qu elle y dresse by kanak n'est
pas content ce moment pour son jt cc
david pujadas un bon soir c'est david
pujadas le playmobil du 20h avec un
casque de cheveux sur la tête
l'information principale de ce journal
c'est bien sûr la météo excécrable
partout en france ainsi que la crise du
logement
un seul français a réussi à résoudre ce
problème il s'agit de gérard louvin qui
a emménagé dans un point soleil françois
cluzet voulez vous donner des nouvelles
aussi françois que je suis nerveuse
droit tout me leroy le brushing de
valeur et ménard
les boucles d'oreilles d'isabelle
m'énerve même la tob de jean michel
madore ces pages il est comme moi et
c'est l'heure pour rien un gilles aubin
alors moi ça c'est mercantile
alors ça ça c'est vieille france c'est
pas digne de m6 à la saint valentin
c'est l'amour wall e comme moi et ce
n'est même pas pour qu'on se leurre
bordeaux alors laura convoi peut enfin
sur les autres plateaux télé si yann
barthès celle de tous ses libertés petit
journal un petit journal on a enquêté
sur un phénomène paranormal mama
suspense quelque chose qui vient d'une
autre galaxie
et oui le rire de cyril hanouna on
écoute un extrait est le gardien
mais comment des clans style ce rire au
petit journal
on a enquêté il ya deux solutions
première solution grâce à un événement
extérieur et bertrand chamerois ses
baskets la deuxième solution cyril
hanouna déclenché tout seul sourire et
ça c'est très pratique
je vous dis les gars bertreau chanot roi
il arrive dans ma loge nous coûte je
voudrais que tu te bats je veux aller
vite
c'est la fin de ce petit journal à la
semaine prochaine air cinéma et au maroc
un axe eux ils font le bonheur de france
durant ce moment c'est nelson monfort et
philippe candeloro
alors que c'est mon cher fait débat je
suis actuellement en direct à sotchi
alors que s'avance maintenant sur la
glace la jeune liang wen chang
il commencera à évoluer avec une grâce
et légèreté ménages sont pas sans
rappeler les villes est un mystère et
toute la sensualité de l'uimm orient je
perds mon cher philippe candeloro
atteint raison nelson et ça a beau être
une chine toc on a quand même envie de
la déglingue
vous vous êtes entouré de jean marc
morandini sur europe bien sûr la voix
des guignols on fait plein de voix de
rien fait qui je veux céline aparté qui
ont été intrigués par comme ça merci ça
moche aussi sur ilan gauguin le gary
parr